you know they say that we are more
divided than ever right that's what they
say whoever the hell they are they keep
saying it and I don't know that that I
believe it but I thought the best way I
could start this that's sort of why I
knew the show is to bring people
together but they keep telling us that
you know we hate each other more divided
so I know maybe you guys should look
around the room and just kind of look
and realize how much you hate everybody
else I mean really take a look at
another table it just really everyone
please don't I'm not just doing this
look really look at each other I mean
but you see yeah you hate them and they
hate you and the white people everybody
else stupid all right but I thought what
i should do actually is taking a little
poll because i want to read the room how
many of you would say that you're
conservatives buy a round of applause
how many conservatives conservatives
always very respectfully you first raise
your hand we don't make a lot of noise
conservative we're conserving the
applause conservatives that's great you
know people with jobs and families I
know you're dressed right nice so I
could have picked you all out it's very
easy oh well there's someone who's
wearing clothes to fit probably a
conservative
many of you are libertarians Liberty a
[Applause]
very special libertarian libertarians
yes anyone that just applauded those are
the people you get back from at the end
of the show libertarian love pot just
quick sidebar I went to one of these you
know I was getting medicinal marijuana
for my glaucoma but then but now it's
legal I guess that you just didn't show
up with your idea or whatever so I went
just like a couple days ago to the pot
shop and impossible to get weed at a
much not have you been that we got oil
we got rocks
we got edibles I was like you have weed
and we form that even a thing I mean I
wasn't in college now I'm going back
that we buy swag is that a word
alright live we did conservatives we did
libertarians how many of you how many
progressives how many progressives I'm
guessing there are but I know because of
the soy sometimes right
I'm a little different in comedy for
there's that's coming back I mean I used
to do this this is what I did okay all
right
so we got not one and no one will say it
I mean we're not gonna take jr. I mean
oh we have one we have what tickly think
about that it's all right it's all right
you're wrong it's great okay so we did
that conservatives we did libertarians
we didn't have any classical liberals of
course we do my people otherwise known
by the the media as a bunch of racist
bigoted homophobes no just kidding those
are good people who believe in the
individual which is what I believe in
all the things that I'm that I'm
constantly talking about and how many of
course to cap this off how many all
right and you can just do it by a show
of hands
[Applause]